So, we are good to go, right?
Yeah, audio is ok, they have said from their side.
Ok.
So, let us begin today's session.
So, my name is Suman Kumar Bhera, I am one of the research scholars in IIT, Kharagpur.
I had a session last week on the basics of Python and how to use some of the platforms
like Anaconda's Jupyter Notebook and Google's Collab to do Python programming.
So, now in this session today, what we will be learning, we will be learning two of the
most important libraries named NumPy and Pandas, which are mainly used for data handling and
data manipulations.
So, apart from your course in artificial intelligence and machine learning, apart from using the
machine learning models, you would be able to convert the data into those machine learning
compatible formats.
And even after getting the output, you may need to do some operations on the output to
get it in the desired format.
So, for those purposes, these two libraries are very much important.
So, I hope everybody is with me and today I will be demonstrating the code in Google
Collab.
So, as you may remember from the last week's session that you would be required to login
to your Google account in your Google Chrome browser.
So, if I can have my screen on the display, I hope this font is good enough for everybody
to view.
So, here as you can see, I have my account logged in.
So, if you are not logged in, so you will not have the facility provided by Google through
this Collab platform which is used for Python programming.
So, I would request everybody to login to their Google Collab, Google account and if
they are not already logged in and open the Collabs link that has been already shared
with you.
So, I will just wait for one minute, so just to get everybody ready if they are already
not.
So, please open this Collab notebook that link has been shared to you.
So, I hope everybody is okay with their Google account logged in.
So, from here what I would want you to do?
I want you to open a new notebook where you would actually code for yourself taking help
of this notebook and whatever I am telling in this session.
So, here coming on this file, what you in the third option there is new notebook in
Drive.
So, if you click this option a new notebook will be created and it will be the notebook
will be automatically saved into your drive, your Google Drive through your login ID.
So, coming here clicking on file you create a new notebook in Drive.
So, here what we have clicking on this file and new notebook in Drive we have a fresh
new notebook.
Here you can change the name of the notebook suppose it is currently untitled 0 IP NYB
that means IPython notebook.
So, you go click on that name and delete whatever written is there that is written there and
you change the name to NumPy Pandas or whatever you feel like you can give it any other name
as per your choice.
So, and here is a cell just let me give a recap.
So, here there are two options one is code and another one is text.
So, you just if you just want to put some description in it like in a cell like here
a text cell has popped up because I clicked on this plus text.
So, here you can write like this so, we will today and you just you do not need to do anything
you just click enter and you have this so, this is the text you put on and if you click
on this code a code cell will pop up with this kind of a button a play button type of
thing.
So, when you click on this play button the code that you have written in this particular
cell gets executed.
And here there is a connect button if you click on this connect then Google collab provides
you the facility of RAM and CPU so, that you can execute your program.
So, as you can see it is connecting and say you have your RAM and disk displayed here.
So, you as you can see connected to Python 3 Google compute engine backend.
So, let us start so, today as in the previous session also you have become familiar with
this ID's data set.
So, now in this course we will be in very depth learn what is this ID's data set what
are the values that are present in here and the pre processing that are required before
directly jumping into a machine learning algorithm or so.
So, just to give you the brief introduction here in this cell here in this cell there
is a link provided there is a link provided and if you just click on this link if you
copy this link, if you copy this link and paste on your browser like this let us see
what you can see.
So, this link provided right here in this cell this cell right below this image of flowers
and if you click on copy this link and paste it on your browser you will be redirected
to something like this and if you zoom in you see some values some values.
So, here this is one row and you will see a lot of rows present here, but one thing
you need to you have to notice that the number of columns in each of this rows is similar
that what is the number of columns present in here.
So, first column, second column, third column, fourth column and fifth column.
So, there are five columns in each of this rows if you scroll down there are five columns
each of this rows.
So, and there are these like floating point values like 5.1, 3.5, 1.4, 0.2 some of these
values like till now not very much human understandable that what they are representing.
And at the last column if you notice something like this iris setosa and if you scroll down
down down down something like iris versicolor and if you scroll further down iris virginica.
So, these are written in the last column.
So, coming back to the Google Colab so, here what we have we have a picture ok.
So, these iris setosa, iris versicolor and iris virginica these are actually three kind
of flowers.
So, these are the pictures of the flowers they are quite similar quite similar not exactly
similar, but quite similar.
So, there is a significant difference between an iris setosa and a rows that is very much
evident, but iris setosa and iris versicolor has relatively less similarity compared to
suppose some other flower like jasmine or rows somewhat like this.
So, and in these flowers what do we have we have a petal and a sepal ok.
So, this is a very nice picture and here we have petal and sepal.
So, you understand what these three kind of flowers is and what are petal and sepal.
So, I hope everybody is clear till this part they understand.
So, getting back to the data set we were contemplating so, here what do we have we have certain values
corresponding to it.
So, now what do you have if you have when you are you want to do some machine learning
deep learning thing you will have a lot of data ok.
So, this data you need to understand that what is the input corresponding to that input
what do we expect the machine learning algorithm to perform that is the output ok.
So, for that purpose just to show you how to gain information regarding that till now
we do not know what are these things like what are these values ok.
So, this archive ok this archive I want you to look at this URL this archive I request
you to this request you to go to this UCI machine learning repository that has the iris
data set.
So, if you just copy this part like this part that has been highlighted so, actually let
me give this in the notebook so, link to UCI.
So, if you actually go to this link copy it and you paste it.
So, you are.
So, this is the archive.
So, you can see this is the link that I have posted and if you go to this link you will
be redirected to this page you would be redirected to the page that has like check this out popular
data sets new data sets etcetera ok.
Now, when we are talking about iris let us click on this iris data set so, we are here.
So, I will wait for 2 minutes for anyone who has not caught up till now ok.
So, this is the data set and the link I have posted there and I request you to go to this
UCI repository and click on the iris data and you will have something like this and those
who have already opened it I would request them to go through whatever written in this
page.
So, this is the data set.
So, I guess we can proceed further now I hope everybody is on the same page with me.
So, here what do we have if we just take a minute to go through whatever in this page.
So, this iris data set that is a very old data set, but that is popular.
So, when you are forming the basis of machine learning a lot of examples come with this
data set ok.
So, here what you have see we are talking about some flowers, their petal, sepul.
So, this subject area is biology the associated task that machine learning task that is associated
with this is classification the feature type is real because if you remember the values
provided here they are like real values ok instances 150 ok.
So, if you actually check that there are actually 150 rows present in here 150 rows and number
of features 4.
So, actually when I was telling you that there are 5 columns in here and the last column
is what type of flower it is and the other 4 are features.
So, number of features 4 ok and if you scroll down so, here what you see variable type table
ok, here what we have we have the information regarding to that those 4 columns.
So, what do those 4 columns that contain those real values actually have.
So, here you can see variable length, sepul length, sepul width, petal length and petal
width.
So, if you remember from the picture that is there on the colab notebook that has the
picture that what is petal and sepul and corresponding to that petal and sepul their length and width
are provided ok.
So, for 150 samples they are petal length and petal width is provided and the unit is
centimeter ok and here you have a nice description see missing values know and there is this last
thing called class target categorical.
So, there are 3 different kind of flowers iris setosa, iris versical and iris virginica
ok.
So, these things are provided ok and this is the baseline model performance that these
things that you will be familiar in the upcoming classes ok.
See exeboost classification has achieved this much accuracy if I zoom out of it.
So, here is like 95 percent 100 percent like accuracy calculation.
So, exeboost classification support vector machines the you will be familiar in the next
classes using neural network classification how what type of accuracy they are achieving
and finally, A would be to beat this accuracy.
So, coming back to this like strange file now we have some understanding regarding the
data.
So, first 4 columns are sepul length, sepul length, sepul width, petal length and petal
width for a corresponding sample of iris setosa in this line.
So, we know what this row means this first row that is highlighted in blue first row
means for a specific sample of iris setosa flower we have the sepul length 5.1, the sepul
width 3.5, the petal length 1.4 and the petal width 0.2 ok.
So, jumping on to our code here what we have we are importing some libraries let us copy
this and paste it in the this blank notebook we have created ok.
So, even if I forget to copy something from that original notebook to this notebook that
we are working out right now.
So, I would encourage you to obviously copy and run it if you are not actually typing
the code.
So, the best thing is learning it from there and typing the code all by yourself, but if
you need to just copy paste something do it not a problem, but actually execute each and
every individual cell.
So, you would be getting the idea that what these things are.
So, here what we have we are importing something import numpy as np.
So, what this thing is as I said this numpy numpy is used for numbers numpy is used for
numbers.
So, we have a lot of numbers so, as you see as you have gone through the data set already.
So, there are a lot of numbers we need to manipulate it and perform operations on to
it.
In the last session also you learned like if I take the easiest of the examples like
you have lot of data you want to calculate the mean, median, mode all those things.
So, these operations and a lot of important operations like calculating eigenvalue, eigenvector
all those things are work of this numpy library.
So, it has it has it is a library that has a lot of facilities a lot of things can be
performed using this numpy and how we are actually calling it in our code like we have
this notebook for ourselves and we want to call that numpy library on to it.
So, here you write import numpy as np and if you just check the version of it
you get some version like 1.26.4.
So, those who are familiar with C code it is somewhat similar to has include stdio.h
something like this when you write C program you include this that has the function definition
of printf scanf all those things.
So, in python we actually import things import the word import you understand general meaning
and we are checking the version of numpy and as np that is not a big thing as np means
for every line when we would be using numpy we just do not want to write numpy n-u-m-p-y
everywhere.
So, we just want to write n-p so, you can put any name here this is just a alias.
So, even if you write numpy as np import numpy as hey hello something like this if you give
it a strange name or you can play around with writing anything here and check the version
it will give the same result see the same result is coming.
So, just to give you a reminder so, if you are executing a particular cell use control
enter that would control enter that would give you the execution of that cell or what
you can do you can click on this play button type of thing here and that would run.
So, usually do not I would not recommend you to write any name as alias here just use n-p
because if you are going through a big code that is already there and you are trying to
understand how things are going on in there you would find the np that is the normal practice
that is the convention.
So, you would find it here so, we are importing numpy as np and in the similar fashion what
we are doing we are importing pandas as pd and these two would not be necessary as we
proceed further in this course I would explain you that what are those things those are mainly
used for plotting something ok. So, here what we have we have a comment that says load the
ish data set ok. So, what we would like to do we would like to load the data and we have
a url. So, in the url that link is provided where the data set was there some strange
floating point values and corresponding to it class and now since we have gone through
the website and we have learnt the details of the data what do we have we know the column
names already ok. So, we have the column names which says sepal length sepal width petal
length and petal width and the last one is species like each of those samples would belong
to a species that is the label there and what we are doing using pd see this pd is the alias
of pandas and read csv. Actually this file is that file if you actually download it if
you actually download it you would be able to notice that it is a csv file and he from
here also you would be able to notice that this is a csv csv means comma separated value.
So, here 5.1 comma 3.1. So, all these values are comma separated. So, that is why that
type of name that csv comma separated value you give the url the url where the data is
provided and you provide the name of the columns that you have you already know about the data.
So, if you write till this and if you actually execute it let us check what it gives. So,
now it is somewhat understandable. So, what do we have we have the column description
right there that first column is sepal length second is width petal length petal width and
species and d 0 then 1 this 2 these are just row numbers and we have nice 3.5 these values
corresponding to these things and we have a species corresponding to this id setosa.
So, now you have a data set loaded with you. So, I will wait for 1 minute for anyone who
has not caught up till this part and then we will jump to other things.
So, here is the data set of the data set of the data set of the data set of the data set. So,
here is the data set of the data set of the data set of the data set of the data set of the data
set. So, I guess everybody is with me on the same page. So, now the thing is when we have
this data set suppose this we have this data set that we wish to work on.
So, suppose suddenly you wish to know the column names the columns that are present in the data.
So, here you need to be familiar with one other like machine learning related term
terminology that these things that are the values provided here are actually features
and this thing is a label. You might be a little confused by now that what actually
features and what actually label is if you are very much new in machine learning,
but eventually you would learn so that is not a problem. So, suppose you wish to know the columns.
So, column the columns are both feature names and label names. So, here you have the data set
iris.df you click just put a dot right here and you write columns.
And you execute that cell as I told you earlier using this play button or control enter and here
you would have the column names. So, we have all the column names.
And here as we proceed further you would be able to learn that this whole data set this whole data
set this iris data set it is used mainly for classification tasks. So, what classification
tasks like you have already seen there are three different kind of flowers and corresponding to
those three different kind of flowers sepal length, sepal width, petal length and petal width values
are provided. So, and as I told you the other terminology that something there exists called
features and something there exists called label. So, all these four values like sepal length,
sepal width and petal length, petal width these are features and corresponding to that the label
species is provided. Now, suppose you do not know how many different species are corresponding to
machine learning problem how many different labels are provided suppose there were four labels
provided. So, we just wish to know that how many labels are there corresponding to which
we need to do the classification. So, we have a certain code here to click to get to a new code
cell what you can do you can click code here or you can when you are present here like this
cursor is blinking you press escape and B. So, a new code would be there and you just
write your code here. So, what do we have here? So,
like even with English like language understanding you can understand it like we have written
irish df. So, this irish df has all the data set and inside of it we are writing what species.
So, you can intuitively understand that the species of this irish df this gives us the species that
are provided like species you remember the names the isetosa iris fussy color all those things
and what we are doing and on those values we just wish to have the unique values dot unique.
So, that is a function that would give from all those values the unique one. So, if you
actually executed what is what this is giving irisetosa iris fussy color iris virginica.
So, these 3 values are provided. So, I will wait for 2 minutes for everybody to catch up till this
part.
So,
I hope everybody has proceeded till this far. So, I hope we can like proceed further.
So, just to give you a recap we imported these 2 important libraries numpy np and pandas and we
from this website where this machine learning data set is provided and understanding the data set
from the website reading some going through some documents we understand these some of
these column names which should be later be recognized with the terms features and level.
We are getting the data from this read csv command from this pandas pd library because those are
comma separated values. So, all the values are separated by comma and we are getting the column
names and we are getting the unique values that are present in the label. So, now getting back here
what we need to do we need to learn a few basics related to numpy and pandas. So,
so after we learn a few basics we will get back to that problem that we are handling
regarding this iris data set because some of this some of this basic numpy and pandas operation
will be necessary for you to understand the things that on high level for machine learning is used.
So, here what we have we have the first example of numpy. So, remember we had in the last class
we learned something called list. So, intuitively you can understand the list means a lot of maybe
similar or dissimilar things. So, I guess in the previous example previous day I gave this
list example list of the nano like all the fruits you need to buy from the grocery store
and says things like that whatsoever. So, and you can understand in the similar manner we can
create obviously create a list like this that will have all the numbers that we wish to work with.
But this list things are somewhat slow somewhat slow this lists are. So, what we do we switch to
arrays. So, not just because of slow these arrays have a lot of upper hand compared to
lists because they provide us a lot of extra facilities that you would be able to understand
eventually as we proceed further and as you develop your machine learning knowledge.
So, what do we have here in this first line with the name that is a variable array 1d
is equals to np dot array and this parenthesis inside this parenthesis like
this is a parenthesis and this is a bracket and this is a curly brace. So,
keep in mind do not be confused how the syntax is. So, if you mess up in this syntax. So,
you will get a syntax error here. So, in this np dot array that means you are trying to create a
numpy array with these numbers what you have you have inside this parenthesis
a bracket and in that bracket you have some numbers. So, this is just an array full of numbers 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 1 dimensional. So, you have a collection of numbers you can understand it like this you
have a collection of numbers 1, 2, 3, 4, 5. Now, if you go to the second line that is written
array 2d here also you can witness the same syntax np dot array and there is a parenthesis.
This parenthesis I am talking about this start of the parenthesis and at the end of the line
it is closing and here what do we have we have a 2d array. So, if you are not familiar with the term
2d array. So, you must be familiar with this term matrix. So, 2d array is essentially a matrix
these parenthesis and brackets these are just fancy ways of writing a matrix like in a computerized
way of writing a matrix. So, and here like let me give you let me explain this theoretically,
but when actually you would execute the code you would be able to understand that what these things
are. So, here the whole thing the whole matrix is enclosed by this bracket this bracket that
is highlighted and it is closed at the end and each individual row each individual row of the
matrix is enclosed in another bracket like 1, 2, 3 this is the first row that is enclosed
in a bracket then 4, 5, 6 that is the second row that is enclosed in another bracket and
in the same manner 7, 8, 9. So, you would be very much clear when you when we actually
execute this. So, if you run this cell like I would encourage you if you have not already like
coded this thing in the blank notebook. So, that is the first thing you should code that in the
blank notebook by yourself and if you haven't already. So, you can copy paste it and when you
actually execute it you get something like this. So, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 list of numbers and 2D array now
it is somewhat looking like a matrix isn't it. So, I hope all of you are familiar with what a
matrix is. So, this is somewhat looking like a matrix still not properly how we write matrix in
our mathematics in with pen and paper, but yeah somewhat like and that matrix is essentially
let me check if I have a picture. So, this is the matrix that we are very much familiar with
in our mathematics that same thing is written there just I told you that enclose this first row
in a bracket the second row also in a bracket and third row also in a bracket and separate those
brackets using commas and this whole thing is enclosed the whole matrix is enclosed in another
bracket that is they are also the same technique is used. So, just 30 seconds I would be waiting
for everybody to complete this part to get the understanding of 1D array and 1D array is also
known as a vector. So, 1D array or vector and 2D array 2 dimensional array or matrix just to be
familiar with please execute this cell.
So, I hope we can proceed further. So, coming down to this coming down to the next cell what
do we have like intuitively. So, if you are if you do not even belong to like coding background
what I would encourage you I would encourage you to understand the coding things that are
like with analogy to natural language like English like language. So, here what this thing print
shape and array 2D dot shape. So, the 2D array that we have created we just want to know the shape
of it the shape of it. So, here you can understand that how many rows and how many columns are present
in that matrix or 2 dimensional array. So, we can understand that there are 3 rows 1 row 2 row
3rd row rows are enclosed by brackets. So, there are 3 rows and corresponding to those 3 rows 3
columns. So, what this should actually give us array 2D dot shape it should be 3 and 3. So,
it is 3 comma 3 this is the type of input. So, we have 3 rows and 3 columns that is the
output here and coming to the second line print data type array 2D dot D type D type means data type.
So, the things that are present in the array 2D what is their data type. So,
dot D type gives you the data type of the elements and then what is this number of dimensions.
So, how many dimensions like of what dimension that particular array is. So, I told you about
this 1 dimensional array or vector then that is dimension is 1 then I told you about this
2 dimensional array or matrix. So, the dimension of a matrix is 2. So, you would get this value.
So, I would encourage you to if you have not actually written this all by yourself. So,
you can what you can do you can copy and paste and you can check its execution in the blank
new book that you are working out. So, let us wait just for 30 seconds and then we will be back to
3D arrays.
So, I hope everybody has understood the 1 dimensional arrays or vectors and 2 dimensional
arrays and matrices. So, we would like to jump to 3D arrays. So, for understanding 3D arrays what
I would suggest you I would suggest you to think about Rubik's cube. So, a Rubik's cube is very
much of a good example of a 3D array. So, as I was saying that like when we have a Rubik's cube
we can imagine that as a 3D array made of 3 2D arrays. So, what a Rubik's cube necessarily is
a 3D array composed of 3 2D arrays. So, one on top of the other. So, 3 matrix like things
on top of each other is forming a Rubik's cube. So, what we are doing in the same manner we are
creating the 3D array. So, array is equals to NP dot array. So, we are putting these values.
So, here what you see 1 2 3 that is itself a row and 4 5 6 that is another row of a matrix that
matrix is enclosed till this part this highlighted part is a matrix a 2D array and another one just
right beside it there is this is other 2D array and the whole thing the whole thing is enclosed
the whole 3D array is enclosed by another bracket. So, if anybody is actually very much new to
programming I would like encourage them to be very much cautious regarding these brackets.
So, these brackets form how like what dimensional array you are actually creating and after these
brackets inside though that parenthesis of NP dot array function what we are writing after the array
we are putting a comma and we are writing D type int 32. So, if you remember from the previous cell
the data type was integer 64. So, that is by default given integer 64,
but now we do not want integer 64 we want integer 32. So, this is the bit number actually 32 is the
number of bits. So, only 4 bytes will be reserved and for that purpose 8 bytes will be reserved.
So, here so, please write the code for the 3D array in the blank notebook that you are
using and if you get any error writing it by yourself then copy, but first please try to
write it all by yourself. And here now the name of the array 3D array
and we are checking the data type of it see the data type it is providing is integer 32.
And check the dimension also.
See when I check ARR dot end beam it is giving me 3. So, I will wait for 30 seconds to for
everybody to catch up till now.
So,
so.
So, now proceeding further I would request you to come to this cell that says something
like this print first row of 2D array. If you actually remember the shape of the 2D array.
If you actually remember the shape of the 2D array it looked something like this.
So, this first thing was first row and remember one thing in Python numbering starts with 0.
So, this row is indicated by 0, this row is indicated by 1 and this row is indicated by 2.
And here if you come at the first statement first row of 2D array is
inside that bracket what is what you need to provide row and column. So, now in place of row
what is written 0. So, what I want I want the 0th row what I want I want the 0th row. And
in column column columns place giving giving the column just like that gives that means all the
columns. So, that means all the columns and in the second statement if it is it is written
first column of 2D array 2D colon then 0. So, at place of row a column is given
colon is given that means consider all the rows and 0 that means only the 0th column.
So, 0th column is 147 first column is 258 and the second column is 369. So, that is given here.
So, I would request you request everyone to catch up till this part and play with these indices.
Instead of 0 try putting try giving 1 and try giving 2 and check what happens and around this
colon also I would request you to give values like 1, 2 play with it by then. So, we will meet after
this short break.
So, I will see you in the next video. Thank you.
Thank you.
.
Okay. So, welcome back everybody. Am I audible?
Super, super fine. So, I hope I am audible. So, so far we have learned arrays of one dimension,
two dimension and three dimension. Now, suppose what we want to do, we want to create a matrix
like this. That is, I hope that is clearly visible on your screen, this matrix, right? That has the
first row as 1.5, 2.5, 3.5, second row as 4.5, 5.5 and 6.5 and the third row as 7.5, 8.5 and 9.5.
So, we have the picture of the matrix clear on your hand. So, I need to scroll down because
the visual space is like quite limited. So, here what we are doing, we are creating this matrix.
So, this is the name we are giving to the matrix says float array. And what we are doing, NP that
numpy as I told you before that numpy has a lot of nice functions that we can be using while
manipulating a lot of numbers. So, here one of the example is like this, np.arrange.
So, what we are doing, we are arranging number
from a certain value to a certain value. So, if you actually look at the first matrix,
you are able to see the value starts from 1.5 and ends at 9.5.
So, here what we have written, 1.5 at the start then a comma and then 10.5. So,
we are starting from 1.5 and ending at 10.5. So, here actually instead of you need to notice this,
instead of 9.5 we are giving 10.5. Because in the for loop also you have noticed if we are
giving the range from 0 through 10, it goes from 0 to 9. So, you have to be careful about that
and data type as floating point 64. And then what we are doing, intuitively you can understand
dot reshape 3 comma 3. Because the shape of this matrix or two-dimensional array or two-dimensional
vector also you can say is 3 cross 3; that means, 3 rows and 3 columns. So, we are arranging these
numbers from 1.5 to 10.5 and we are reshaping it to 3.3 comma 3. And we are printing the
floating point array. So, it would look something like this. So, there are actually 9 elements. So,
9 elements are reshaped into 3 comma 3 size array. So, let us play with this just for a single minute.
So, suppose I am giving here 1 then 8. Let us give 1 then 9. And let us remove this reshape
function and let us print it. Check what it gives. It gives me from 1 through 8 all these numbers.
And there is a dot right beside every number. So, this dot actually means that 8.0. So,
floating point because we have given the d type; that means, data type as floating point.
If we change the floating 64 to integer 64 then this dot would disappear.
I hope this thing will clear all your doubts if you were having anything by now. So, how many
elements do we have? We have 8 elements. Now, suppose we wish to use this reshape function.
So, using this reshape function on top of an array that has 8 elements, what shape we can derive?
Like a matrix of how many rows and how many columns. We can give this like 4 comma 2.
Now, what 4 comma 2 would mean? Like 4 rows and 2 columns. So, we are writing a reshape type of
thing reshape R E S H P E reshape 4 comma 2 the intended value. So, if we execute this.
So, I have written the spelling round. So, are we getting a matrix of 4 rows and 2 columns?
So, think about this if we write 4 comma 3 here would that be successful?
I want you to think for think this for a while like for 10 seconds just think about it if we
give the reshape to 4 comma 3. Those who have guessed like this would be wrong
are correct because 4 comma 3 that would mean a row of a matrix of 4 rows and 3 columns that would
have 12 elements. So, we actually do not have 12 elements. So, it would run into an error.
But what we can do? We can write 2 comma 4 right 2 rows and 4 columns.
And when you are specifying a row size like given here with 2 column size would automatically
can automatically be determined. You can understand that corresponding to a specific row size column
size would be like already known you cannot put arbitrarily value right there. So, sometimes
if you go through machine learning code you would encounter something like negative 1.
So, what negative 1 does is essentially the same thing as explicitly mentioning the
value. So, and one other thing you can do with this 8 element
array. So, 2 comma 2 comma 2 if you write it like this and execute it what you would have
just check this out what we have right try understanding the brackets. Those who have
guessed correctly that we are getting a 3D matrix 3 dimensional matrix are correct. So,
so this concept this reshaping concept would be important for you when you are working with
data sets like like when you would be learning deep learning and convolutional neural networks
all those thing then this like when you have a grayscale image that would be considered as a
2D 2 dimensional arrays with all those grayscale values and when we are talking about a an RGB image.
So, for 3 different R, G and B 3 channels you have separate matrices of values. So,
that would be considered as a 3D array. So, at that time you maybe need to use this reshape
kind of thing and there a lot of time this negative 1 is used. So, what else you can do
you can create a 0 arrays. So, now I hope I have given you the flavor of coding like how to understand.
So, 0 array np dot 0s. So, you wish to make a an array full of 0s. So, 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 something
like that and of what shape say 2 comma 3 shape and what would be the data type of those elements
that is integer 64 ok in the same manner 1 array. So, array full of 1s ok. So, np dot 1s 2 comma 3
of that same shape, but all the elements are now 1 instead of 0 and what is this full array. So,
2 of 2 comma 2 shape, but all the elements would be 99 ok and you can print those things. So,
I would encourage you to please do this coding all by yourself. So, you would be able to understand
I am printing the 0 array that has 2 rows and 3 columns all 0. So, please code it with me please
or at least copy it and execute in your blank notebook to check the things that are going on
1 array and full array ok. So, let me wait for 1 minute.
So, I hope everybody is done now we will jump back to the problem that we were tackling at the
beginning of dot that irish data set.
So, now in this cell what we are doing we had in irish data frame if you remember something
called sepal length. So, the column that contains the sepal length for all those 150 samples we are
taking that and we are converting that to a numpy array np dot array and we are in this
variable what we are getting that array sepal length and in the same manner sepal width ok.
So, please code this and what we are doing we are calculating the mean sepal length from all
those 150 samples using this function np dot mean. So, as I was saying that compared to list
arrays provide the numpy arrays provide a lot of facilities one of the some of those facilities
you have already come across like reshaping like arranging value from in between ranges
and now this is mean. So, you are getting the mean np dot mean. So, you do not need to explicitly
write a program of calculating mean from all the values that we have what you can do you
can just write this np dot mean and you would have a mean value and np dot std you can understand
this is the standard deviation ok. So, what we are doing we are calculating the mean and standard
deviation of sepal length and sepal width ok. So, we what we are printing we are printing the
mean of sepal length and standard deviation of sepal width. So, this is coming something like this.
So, this is like some linear algebra type of things that can be performed with numpy.
So, let us wait for 30 seconds for everybody to catch up.
So, proceeding further what we have we are doing some operation that has the we have already had
all the sepal lengths in this variable right sepal length and for all the values in this
sepal length variable which are greater than mean sepal length of 5.84 would be marked as true
right here and the remaining would be false. So, all these operations are done using these
facilities see just by using this greater than sign we can achieve this and we are printing
there those large sepal. So, these particular flowers would have like already have large
sepal lengths ok. I would request you to get the picture clear. So, at the so please code this
on your own or copy paste and check out the output. So, by the time I would recapitulate a few things.
So, what you had you had flowers 150 flowers and from those flowers you had the sepal lengths
and you had it in a data frame of different columns. So, you had this column named sepal length and
what we calculated we calculated the mean of all those values. So, the mean is saved in this
variable mean sepal length and all the values that are present in that column if those values are
greater than this mean sepal length then we are saving it in large sepal variable ok and we are
printing it. So, it would have some true and false values true for large sepal that are greater than
the mean and false for small sepal that are lower than the mean. And we are printing flowers with
large sepal in the sepal length putting this large sepal value. So, here these are the
large sepal you can check all these values are greater than 5.84 that was actually the mean
sepal length ok. So, now here some pandas operations are described. So, Irish DF try to get the picture
clear in your head Irish DF this part this had all the data set the big data set that you
downloaded no not downloaded using the URL you had the data ok. Now, there is this bracket
and inside this bracket what we are writing Irish DF and sepal length. So, you have all the sepal
length and if those sepal lengths on those rows is greater than the mean sepal length then show me
those rows from this Irish DF whole data set. So, here you see this 50, 51, 52 all these values
then these values like 70 rows out of 150 rows have like a sepal length that is greater than
the mean of those values ok. So, in this manner you will have it let me wait for 30 seconds for everybody to code it.
So,
ok I hope everybody has done till this part. So, here what we would be witnessing would be
witnessing a few facilities provided by this pandas library. So, you have the whole Irish
data set in this Irish DF data frame and what you are doing you are using this describe function
using this describe function to describe intuitively you can understand describe all those
things. So, you have this four columns and I told you that there are count 150 means 150
samples are there and you have the mean corresponding to all those columns standard deviation all those
things ok. And then what we are doing we are exploring some more pandas facilities here what
we have write we have write dot head; that means, the first 5 values let me see ok. So,
with this head what we are getting we are getting the first 5 check this out the row index 0, 1,
2, 3, 4; that means, 5 total 5 values are being shown here ok. And this is you probably have
already understood see in the data frame also if you give a starting index and an ending index
you would able to you would be able to get those values. So, here I hope you would be able to
understand when we are giving 0 colon 10 from 0 through 9 we would be able to see ok. So,
and here print the info we are printing the info that what whatever is present there and
data types ok. So, some info would be there like range index 150 because 150 samples are here and
entries starting from 0 through 149 ok. And when we are checking the d types corresponding to the
data frames what we are getting the sample length is floating point 64 all these things are floating
point 64 and species since it is in a string like format not integer not floating point
that is why its d type is given as object. And there are total 150 values and null count means
all the values are completely fulfilled in the data frame. So, none of the values are empty
or given null or NAN not a number those type of things and how much memory it is using and all
those things ok. And suppose we wish to get specific specifically how many
values are there in the data frame of a specific species suppose we wish to have the number of
iris setosa samples. So, here what like intuitively please try to understand if you are new iris df
then species. So, species that was giving you the three kind of species and this is equals to is
equals to means is that equal to. So, is that equal to iris setosa. So, if it is iris setosa
then save it in the iris s. So, when we are giving iris s dot shape then that means actually
50 samples and five columns corresponding to it that is why the five value five columns
for each of these rows we were having that is why. So, in the same manner you can get the
versicolor also the same code is repeated here for versicolor that we just encountered for iris
setosa ok. So, please do till this much and let me wait for one minute.
So,
ok. So, I hope everybody has done till that part. So, here what we are doing suppose all the
feature values that were already provided in a data set you are not like satisfied with this
and suppose you are your machine learning model does not work very well with all those
corresponding values and you wish to include new features represented by columns in the data set.
So, what you can do using this pandas. So, suppose here we had several lengths and several width.
So, like multiplying several length with several width would obviously give you something like
several area. So, I this is just an example I actually do not know that several area something
like several area would actually be good for like for a machine learning model to understand
the difference between three type of petals or three type of flowers or not. But just to show you
how things take place. So, iris df several lengths and times several width and we are
saving it in a new column called several area ok. So, we have several length several area
and at the end we have a new column named several area, several area would be this times this several
length time several width ok. So, I will wait for 30 seconds for you to check how you can
generate a new column corresponding to some new values.
So, I hope everybody is done. So, now we are at the like almost at the end of our session.
So, here what we are trying to do we are trying to plot the data that we were having
using some visualization things. So, here though those import libraries would be necessary
like import mat plot lib and import c borne as sn sns ok. So, what we are doing we are doing a
scatter plot with the data sns dot scatter plot like scatter the values like this and
data is iris data x the x coordinate is several length the y coordinate is several width
and u is species. So, you have the species here corresponding to each color and plt dot title
means give the title give this title to the image. So, let us try to view this let me zoom out. So,
here you have the thing. So, in blue color you have the scatter plot of iris setosa in orange
you have iris versey color and in green you have iris virginica ok. So, just like out of nowhere
try to imagine since we were like since the beginning we were considering this as a classification
task that means classify between these three classes of flowers. So, suppose you have this
scatter plot and think about this that you can clearly draw a line right here check out where
the mouse is moving you can clearly draw a line right here and separate the iris setosa.
Isn't that possible like you can easily separate this iris setosa because they are like far apart
from this mixture of virginica and versicolor right. So, you understand this right by visualizing
the data you would be able to understand the patterns of those data and those patterns would
be later help you understanding the machine learning algorithm how those function ok.
So, now what we are doing this pair plot is a nice thing pair plot means corresponding to
each individual feature compare it with the other feature and plot it. So, intuitively you
you would be able to understand if you visualize this whole image we are giving this iris df whole
thing and use the hue. So, we would be able to understand it. So, previously we were plotting
something like this something like this right corresponding to petal length and
suppose sepal length sepal width something like this this was the image. So, in this image
please check out the cursor in the in this image like the blue ones can be separated.
Suppose just think about it taking a pencil you wish to draw a line on this image. So,
drawing a line would separate the blue, but drawing a line would not separate how would you
draw the line a straight line it is tough to draw a straight line right here right.
So, now coming to this picture. So, here you can draw a straight line separating the blue values
and see a straight line at this point between this mixture of orange and green would also
separate this somewhat better than the previous one right. A line here and another line here
somewhat it would better differentiate ok. So, corresponding to these values and check out
all the other plots I would request you when you actually study this part.
Check out how different type of features sepal width petal length would give you different
visualizations through which like consider this this image right there it is very bad right.
So, draw a line to separate the blue dot green dot from the orange dot it would be a messed up
task right. So, these features like sepal width and sorry sepal width and sepal area that is a
like bad feature and compare if you compare it with this one like petal width and petal length
petal length is written here petal width is written here just two straight line one here and one here
do your job right. So, coming to this part what we are doing we are plotting a correlation matrix
ok. So, correlation you must have learned it in the mathematics session. So, corresponding to each
feature and other feature what is the correlation. So, here you can see correlation of sepal length
with sepal length is obviously one. So, sepal length with petal length see how the correlation is high
between sepal length and petal length. So, that is a like these two are good features
comparing petal length with sepal width this is bad right. In this manner you would be able to
understand and at the end we are just using this C bond we are plotting this in a nice picture the
same thing is in this colorful picture here and the last thing for now for today is when you have
when like in the label section in the species column here in this dataset you have three
values like the name of three flowers when you are actually training a machine learning model the
model would not understand the names like that what you will have to do you will have to map
those names onto numbers like sound fancy, but nothing tough like wherever in the dataset
there is iris setosa write 0 there wherever there is iris versicolor in the dataset write 1 here
there and wherever it is virginica write 2 there ok and using this code like iris df and I said map
this is mapping right corresponding to a specific label you are mapping a number to it.
So, map this thing and you will have if you print the head the first five values you will
get here. So, here in the species you see all 0s because the top columns top rows were iris setosa
and we have mapped 0 corresponding to 8. So, this much for today we will take a short break
of two minutes and we will get back to question answer session I would encourage you to do these
coding by again in the blank notebook that you have created.
[BLANK_AUDIO]